my Jesus. So these were inventions of my mind. So she's questioning herself here.
And my beloved Jesus moved in my interior. Now here's my two texts for moving in my interior
and you'll know them off by heart by now at Luke 1721, the Kingdom of God is within you.
And one Corinthians 3 16, no you not that you are the temple of the living God and the spirit of God
dwells in you. So Jesus said my daughter you must know that this way of praying that is to look
quite bad in love for all the things created by him is a divine right. Everything came out from him
pure love and what he wants is that someday the human race will come back to him in pure love
and the circuit is complete. This is a divine right he said and enters the first beauty of the creature.
The creation was made for a love of man. Now he's going to repeat that over and over and over again
in the coming sections of volume 18 and volume 19 and he's going to say to us that we really
need to go outside and to really look what God has done to appreciate something of the enormity of his
love. Everything was made for a love of man. Even more our love was so great that if it had been
necessary we would have created as many heavens, suns, stars, seas, earth, plants and all the rest
or eat individual. If it was necessary he would have given an entire universe to you.
Amazing. Why? He can do anything. He has everything. He's all powerful. He's omnipotent.
He can do anything. No bother. If we needed it he would do it. But he's going to explain that
wasn't actually necessary because all of us can experience it all as if we were the only ones
experiencing it. So the each one of us would have a creation all for ourselves, a universe
all of our own. Now put beside that Jeremiah 31 3 I have loved you with an everlasting love
and I am constant in my affection for you. Also I want you to put Sam 145 verse 17
God only ever acts out of love. God is love. That's his character. The only motive he has for doing
anything is love. So and in fact Jesus said that everything was created. Adam was the only
spectator in all of creation. He could enjoy all the good that he wanted. And if we did not give
a universe for each individual it's because man could enjoy everything anyway as if it were his own.
Even if others also might enjoy it. So Jesus said can't all of you say the sun is mine?
No matter how much sun you want to take that doesn't block anybody else from having it.
You can enjoy the light of the sun as much as you want. Or you can say the water is mine
and quench your thirst whenever you have a need. Or you can say that about the sea or the earth
or the fire or air. These are all my things. And so with many other things created by me Jesus.
And if it seems that man lacks something that he suffers hardship. Now he's ramping this message
for all the volumes. If we are actually suffering it's because of sin. Because sin bars the way
to God's benefits. It also prevents the things created by God from being abundant
or the ungrateful creature. So when we're going through the earth and the earth is not
corresponding with us it means divine will is in the earth and divine will is having a struggle with us.
So given all this Jesus said and in all creation things God bound his love towards his creature.
That means when you pluck an apple off an apple tree you are actually reaching out to receive his
love. When you pluck a potato out of the ground that's his love. When you take the carrot out of
the ground it is love. When you look at the magnificence of the roads or the lily you're
looking straight into his face. In all created things God bound his love towards each soul.
And that it was the duty of the soul for the quiet God with her little love with her gratitude
with her thank you. The one who had done so much for her. Now all of you who are married know this
all much better than me and that is that if your little child comes in having plucked your best
rose hasn't even caught it properly and brings it into you and offers you this glorious rose and
says mommy or daddy I know or to everything because it's spontaneous love. It's coming straight from
the heart of this little creature and that's what God is looking for from us. That love will come
spontaneously from within the depths of our being. And so not from quieting God in love for everything
he has done for man in creation it's the first fraud. It's the first fraud that the creature makes
against God is to use surface gifts without even recognizing where they come from and without
recognizing the one who gave the gift. So that means you become a very careless user because you're
not looking at the source you're not looking at the love that is there and you are not responding in
love either. Therefore this is the first duty of the creature Jesus says and this duty is so
indispensable it is so important that she who took part that she is our blessed mother. We took part
in all of our glory our defense our interest if nothing would go around through all the spheres
from the smallest to the greatest thing created by God in order to impress her quite love, glory,
thanksgiving for all and in the name of all human generations. That's why he wants us to put our
I love you I praise you I thank you I bless you on absolutely everything as well. I call that
putting your signature on God's creation. It's not enough that he has everybody else's signature.
Francis is here as well so Francis needs to be written on creation as well. She says yes in love
for the trees and the bushes and the flowers and in the creepy crawlies.
Ah yes it was precisely my celestial mother who filled heaven and earth with the requital of
everything that God had found in creation. After her she was first in my humanity because now we're
talking about human history which filled this duty so holy in which the creature has so very
much failed. Now one of the identifications of the human race in these writings is ungrateful man
man meaning the human race and so we have a lot of reparation to make and a lot of boys to fill in.
So after our message mother came my humanity which filled this duty so holy in which the creature
had very much failed and rendered my celestial father benevolent towards guilty man. Now notice
that when somebody does complete this circuit of love that you actually touch the heart of the
father to look at the human race with a different face. Therefore it will mitigate chastisements
things won't be as bad as they were. So these were my prayers Jesus said
and these were the prayers of those of my inseparable mother. Don't you want them to repeat these very
my prayers? Even more is why I've called you into my will that you may associate yourself with us
and follow and repeat our acts. What an enormous privilege my goodness for absolute nobodies to be
able to join Jesus and Mary in their requital of love to the father so that our little nothing
can be lifted up onto a great height because of him. It's incredible and not only that but
in the next paragraph he tells us that when we do our rounds it's music in his ears.
So I tried Louisa said as much as I could I love that statement because we can't do the same thing
all the time it depends on your emotional state it depends on all kinds of things. I did as much as
I could to go around to all creation things we give to my God the record love glory and gratitude
for everything he had done in creation. I seemed to see all creation things in all creation things
the requital of love of my empress mother from my beloved Jesus. I call this the divine signature
she seemed to see it everywhere. That blessed mother had touched everything.
This requital formed the most beautiful harmony between heaven and earth and bound the creator
of the creature. Each requital of love was a key to mean a musical key a little sonata of an
rectoring celestial music and my sweet Jesus added my daughter all created things were nothing
other than an act of my will that issued them. Or can they move or change the effects the position
or the office with which have been given by the creator. They are nothing other than mirrors
in which man was to admire the reflections and the qualities of the creator of 32 Corinthians
3 18. The more we contemplate God the more God image is imprinted upon us.
And Jesus says that in some of the created things he put his power like the wind like the sea.
In some he put his beauty like the wonderful flowers and in other things he put his goodness
like you know the fruits and all the vegetables we get he put his immensity in the marvel of the
oceans what is light in the sun and so on. So I want to give you Sam 1 4 8 there that where the
Sam is really glorifies God creation. In some each created thing preaches to man the qualities
of the creator. I love that. So I want to give you the book of Daniel chapter 3 from verse 71
and it's the wonderful hymn of praise and gratitude of the three men in the fiery furnace. It's the
most incredible thing and when you realize that it's written under the dire circumstances that
these men are experiencing and the praise is all the more pure all the more beautiful and so they
ask heaven and earth and everything to praise God. And Jesus says that all created things with their
mutual voices tell how much I love them. Now Sam 19 verses 1 to 6 will tell you that the heavens
that they are the glory of God and they proclaim the glory of God to the whole of creation without
saying anything. What I've got to do is look listen understand there isn't enough look listen and
understand going on in the human race today. We're looking at the wrong things which is the
internet and television and cinema and all kinds of stuff. They don't know what listening is so
they will never hear. And so the tragedy is that that Christians are saying they can't hear God
but put away all the distractions and you'll be surprised. On the other hand in creating man
Jesus said it was not just our will but an emanation that came out of our womb and emanation
means a divine spark. The you and I are a divine spark and it's very interesting I have watched
last year or the year before I think it was all series of programs on how the universe has made
you can get this on the television. And the people who are presenting these programs ended up by saying
you know you and I are stardust. It's really fantastic and they were getting closer and closer
to the reality of who we actually are a divine spark. Something that came out of that divine
fire and it will never ever ever rest until it goes back into the divine fire from which it came.
In creating man it was not just our will but an emanation or a divine spark that came out of our
womb a part of ourselves that we infused into him. That's why we're in the image of God. That's
Genesis 1, 27 and Genesis 2, 7. And this is why we created him with the free will.
Why we're so different to everybody else. That he might always grow in beauty, wisdom and virtue.
Now if you look at Luke 2, 52, Saint Luke's Gospel, Luke 2, 52, you'll hear a very simple thing
stated that Jesus as a child grew in age and wisdom and grace before God and man. And Jesus is
saying that's the model for all of us. So if we're not growing in wisdom we're not growing at all.
Because you won't understand anything without wisdom. Wisdom is one of the very early steps
on the ladder. And if we don't have virtue there's no balance whatever in our being.
And when we grow in wisdom and virtue beauty appears. Doesn't matter how ugly we are on yet.
Because this beauty comes from within and it flows outside. So in our lightness man could
multiply his goods and his graces. So in the next section which is I have a VIP on the next paragraph
I think it's fantastic. We're told that creation was made to serve man. But man was made to serve
God. A humble man comes around to serve God. He's out of order. I mean if a washing machine doesn't
wash clothes and a dishwasher doesn't wash dishes what is it doing there? Oh if the sun had free will
it could take two suns out of one and four out of two but glory of what honor will
not give to its creation. How much glory for itself as well.
Yet what the creation things cannot do because they are without a free will they cannot make a
decision. And because they were created to serve man all of them man can do because he was created
to serve God. So because we were created to serve God all our love was centralized in man.
And this is why we placed all creation at his disposal.
Everything was all ordered around him that man might make use of our works like as many stares and
ways in order to come to us to know us and to love us. This is a 19 again that all of creation
steps of the stairs is going back to God. And John 1 51 the lovely day to say it as well
the angels of God ascending and descending in the communication between God and the human
that makes it so that God's will is done on earth as it is in heaven and the angels have that very
much as something that wants to be accomplished immediately. What is not our sorrow in seeing that
man below our sorry in seeing man the word operating should be there below our created things.
And what he means is all creation has the divine will in it every tree every plant every animal
and so on the divine will is there they don't know free will the divine will is preserving them
enabling them to do everything. All of them are in the divine will as the mute creatures they are.
but the one who has free will opted out to do his own will and so Jesus says that human beings
outside of God's will are operating below a level of all creation and we're going to hear
in the messages that are coming throughout the whole of volume 18 that is why when human beings
become too rebellious against God that the rest of creation rebels against man so you get your
hurricanes you get your tsunamis you get your earthquakes you get your volcanoes. Now if you've
been living since the 20th century you might be older I don't know all of this stuff has become
sort of normal we're so used to disasters we think they're normal. No no they increase
with the rebellion of the human race and everything will come back into order once the human race
comes into order. So the big challenge for us is to get into the divine order ourselves individually
get our marriages into the divine order get our families into the divine order get our churches
into the divine order and then you'll be amazed society will follow because they're lost
they're so lost in fact they didn't follow anybody in any direction which they are doing right now
so the horrible thing for the Lord is to see the human race operating below the level
of the creation around us even more his beautiful soul given to us by God transformed into the
ugliness of sin. Now I want you to look at that expression his beautiful soul we have no idea
of what the soul looks like in God's eyes but as you go on in these writings you will find
he wants to make an entire new creation inside of us when he's already told us
he wants to put a complete new universe inside of us so that there will be a gospel according
to Francis a gospel according to your name and it will be a new gospel it will still be loved
and joy and peace and patience and kindness and all the fruits of the spirit but it will have
the specialness of who you are and it will be very special in the whole mosaic of creation
because when you look out at the enormity of the variety in trees and shrubs and yet each one of
them is very distinct and has very different characteristics to the others so there's something
about you Lord wants that's why he allowed you to come in fear doesn't matter what your parents
thought and even if they taught you're a mistake it actually doesn't matter well it's what God
wanted it actually matters even more his beautiful soul given by us transformed into the ugliness
of sin now the ugliness of sin means chaos the exact opposite of the divine will and it is
exact opposite of the divine order and his beautiful soul stunted in good
we all grieve when we see a plant that we have planted becomes stunted and we don't know why
it's not growing and we grieve that this this little thing is not reaching its full potential
we can't even imagine how much the Lord grieves over us but Jesus has tried really hard to tell
Louisa and he said not only stunted in good but horrible to look at it now when you go to the hours
of the passion Jesus went to great trouble to reveal to Louisa that when you look at the horrible
scourging and the equally or more horrible crowning and the extraordinary way that human beings
behave towards Jesus you're looking at human beings behaving way below power way below and the
horror and the ugliness in their own lives eventually became depicted on his life so the
enslavement of the human soul was actually depicted in Jesus's nailing to the cross
he was enslaved on the cross the unbelievable wounds of the human soul were depicted in the
myriad wounds on his body he actually looked the picture of sin thing Paul tells us that
I forget the reference I think it's Roman 4 maybe 5 he was made sin into us that he was literally
you look at him in the passion and you say that is what the human soul looks like in rebellion
against God and it's horrific it's horrific and it's when we come to realize just the sheer horror
of sin that we start shifting we start moving because there is such a draw from society and
and there's such a draw from our lower nature as well to go down into this place of chaos
but when enough human beings in a society have reached this chaos then society itself
was into rebellion and chaos you'll see this on your television screens when you turn on the news
that an awful lot of countries today rebellion chaos murder further everything the killing of
children and the wanting to kill off the old goes on and on and on and on the horror
horrid to the side now the thing is it's one thing for me to say that but we're looking at a text in
which Jesus is speaking God is saying that a human being in that condition is horrible in his sight
and you know from Hebrews 1214 nothing unholy or unworthy can enter the presence of God
so if you die in that condition you're going to a horrible place don't recommend it
his beautiful soul that he made and you know when a person is growing in in union with Jesus
and they're so they're allowing their soul to be transformed more and more and more
we go to the song of songs and you hear the beloved saying how beautiful you are
how beautiful you are my love my love when he's seeing his own divine order coming back
into that soul and he's seeing love coming back into it and he's he's seeing all the
magnificence that he intended going back into that soul here you have the grieving side of it
but I think we really need to look at this to make sure that we don't allow the enemy to fall us down
yet he says as if everything that was created for him was not enough to our love in order to preserve
his free will we gave him the gracious gifts in creation the gift that surpassed all other gifts
we gave him the divine will now I want you to notice something there because some of this
material has been given in victim pieces Jesus is the most incredible teacher he goes back over
material and he fills in this little spot and visited this spot and the other little spot to
make sure you get it and here he's saying that the only thing that can preserve the human will
as God wants it to be is the divine will without the divine will the human will really deteriorate
so we gave him our will he said to preserve his free will so our will placed itself
at man's disposal to give him all those aids which man might need so there you have it we've
come to create it ourselves for the divine will and the lord is saying if you've come to be to
consecration the divine will all the aids that you need are at your disposal everything everything
you need to come to that inseparability with him is there at your disposal our will was given to him
as primary life now the church has always told us that God is the prime mover and so
that the divine will would be the origin of our actions the origin of our thoughts the origin of
our words the origin of our motivations it wouldn't just be thinking of a sort of afterwards and say
oh and I sort of meant that it will hire a level no the divine will would actually be the source
our will was given to him as primary life and as the first act in all his works having to grow in
grace and in beauty he needed a supreme will which would not only keep company with this human will
what would substitute for the operating of the creature uh-huh he alone can do divine acts
so if we don't let the divine will take over and how can the act be divine
I'm only capable of human acts his will has to take you he has to substitute for us
and so what he said this great gift man also despised he then he said how our will enters the
primary life of the creature it's and as long as the divine will maintain its first act
its life the picture grows always in grace light and beauty now here is a way of
the searching for yourself are you growing and that is that Jesus and he's got to say this over
and over and over again that if the divine will is in fact operating in our thoughts in our
words in our actions in our motivations and everything we will in fact be growing in grace
in light and in beauty now beauty is divine order
she preserves the bond of the first act of our creation and we received the glory of all
created things because they serve our will operating in the creature the only purpose of our creation
everything was for us I don't think we can imagine the
horror that we gave to God God gave us love we gave him sorrow
therefore Jesus said I recommend to you to let our will be more than life for you
and to let it be the first act of all your actions so that's exactly what we must aim at
so if you're coloring something make sure you colored that last line okay I've gone on a bit
about that but that's our foundation in automating so let's go to the August the 15th
so Louisa said I continue to use myself in the holy divine position to requite my Jesus
with my little love for everything he has done from mankind and creation and my beloved Jesus
moving in my interior there's your lube 1721 again in order to give more value to my little love
did what I was doing together with me that there's the point number one there's the one you underlined
to give more value to my acts he did it with me we do something with the divine will
so meanwhile he told me my daughter all created things were made from man see to where he makes
a point and he starts developing it and all of them run towards man
they've no feet but they all walk and they have no motion either to find him or to be found by him
the light of the sun departs from the height of the heavens in order to find the creature
to illuminate him and to warm him the water walks of course it's just symbolic naturally you know
means that the creation is actually moving towards the human race to serve for some reason I wrote
down Matthew 18 19 forget why I put it there so the water does the same thing to quench our
tarts and so on then the plants and the seeds rip up the earth and forms the fruit because
themselves to man it's not one created thing that doesn't have a step emotion towards the one
whom the eternal maker had directed it in its creation so every single thing is directed towards
us when you eat the apple apple is delighted because it's done the divine will it has served you
everything is served and we'll come to that my will maintains the order and the harmony
and keeps them all underway round man he keeps everything in order so it's my will that walks
constantly towards man so what these are the saying is first of all notions
that the whole of creation is serving you and secondly go a little bit deeper and find out
what is it in creation that makes it serve you and Jesus said is the divine will
I just find that absolutely amazing because Jesus said in Mark 10 45 that the son of man did not
come to be served but to serve and to give his life as a ransom for this ungrateful human race
he not only gave everything he was and everything he had he gave his life as well
it's this inexplicable love that it shows me all the time and it leaves me unable to say anything
or tinker or anything but lift a door
so it's the divine will serving us it's incredible and what are we serving we're serving ourselves
the human race is serving itself it's selfish self-centered wanting everything for itself
and here you have God himself humbling himself in this inexplicable manner
I don't know about you but it on does me
so he said my will is what actually is constantly going towards man within all created things
it never stops it's all motion towards the one that it loves so much
Jeremiah 31 three yet who says thank you to my will do you remember the time Jesus healed the
10 lepers where are the other nine nine tenths of creation of should say our humanity totally
ignoring the God who picks them everything who says thank you and that's why in all of our prayers
and all of our rounds we make sure there's thank you in there and sometimes I just say to the Lord
I want to thank you in your will for everything I want thank you I want to thank you I want to make
sure you're going to make sure somebody thanks you in a loving way who says thank you to my will
now he tells us so frequently that the human race is ungrateful that that's an area where
we've got to really make reparation who says thank you to my will which brings in the light of the
sun and the water and the food and everything else is it not right since my will knows everything
for men that he should do everything to fulfill my will there's divine logic since God is doing
everything for us isn't it just logical that we would turn around and do everything for him
but if we don't the next paragraph tells us that nature gets disgusted with us and nature
goes into rebellion against us now notice we laid all the foundations in the first message
and we get the illustrations here oh if you knew the feast that my will makes in created things
and it walks to and serves that notice the serves the one who fulfills my will my will operating
and fulfilled in the creature and my will operating in created things and my text says kiss each other
we would say unite in ordinary English unite as they meet and harmonize they love one another
and form the him of adoration for their creator and the greatest portion of all creation when
the two actually harmonize it's really fantastic so creation feels honored that's Romans day 19
when they serve a person who is animated by the same will animate them which forms their very
life on the other hand my will takes the attitude of sorrow Ephesians 430 don't grieve the holy
spirit and my will takes the attitude of sorrow in those same created things when it has to serve
one who doesn't do my will and this is why it happens that many times watch this now because
this explains for tapping around the world as we go on and it's going to get worse until the
human being stopper Valley this is why at many times created things place themselves against man
they strike him and they chastise him because they become superior to him the reason for that is
that they keep intact within themselves the divine will by which they were animated from the very
beginning while man has descended down below and he does not keep the will of the creation
now notice we've been told all creation was made for man man was made for God
when man moves away from God and creation stays in the will of God because they don't have free will
then creation and man are a clash and I think we've arrived at the earth rebelling against us
there's so many signs all over the world I'm not going to because the time is running out
so and then we have this beautiful thing that I read for you on the 15th of August
after this Louisa said I began to think about the feast of our blessed mother assumed into heaven
and my sweet Jesus with the tender and moving pon said my daughter the true name for this feast
should be the feast of the divine love was the human will that closed heaven broke the bonds
with its creator made miseries and sorrow enter the field and put an end to the feast
that people were to enjoy in heaven now this lady queen of all by doing the will of the eternal
one always and in everything notice the always and notice in everything we're inclined sometimes
to give ourselves a little time out which is all wrong
always and in everything even more it can be said that her life was the divine will alone
opened the heavens bound herself to the eternal one and restored in heaven the feasts with the
creature every act she did in the supreme will was a feast that she started in heaven
it was suns that she formed to adorn this feast it was melodies that she sent in the light of the
celestial Jerusalem now notice the celestial Jerusalem has to descend to the earth for a while
so the true cause of this feast is the eternal will operating and fulfilled in our blessed mother
so in another place at another time we have to look at just what happened in her
and through her and because of her it's amazing because you just get a little summary here
the divine will operated such properties in her as to establish heaven and earth
chain the eternal one with insoluble bones of love and captured the word even in her womb
captured the divine word even in her womb the very angels were enraptured and repeated among
themselves from queer come so much glory so much on earth such greatness and prejudice never seen
before this excelling creature and yet she's coming from the exile and i want to give you the song of
songs chapter eight verse five who is this coming up from the desert leaning on her beloved the bride
astonished they recognize the will of their creator as life operating in her
and trembling they said holy holy holy now honor and glory be to the will of our sovereign lord
now this trisagion that is the triple holy holy holy you get this in the book of revelation
in chapter four okay and these are all the dwellers of heaven the clearing before of god the
incredible holiness of his person and what jesus is saying here is that when blessed mother
arrived in heaven in the assumption they said that to the divine will that she brought with her from
the earth same person dwelling in her was also dwelling in the celestial father so holy holy
holy honor and glory to the will of our sovereign lord and glory and trice holy she who let this
supreme will operate wonderful stuff you just need to read that slowly and prayer and let it sink in
and just give your praise as an earth's one so it is my will that more than anything was and is
celebrated on the day of the assumption into heaven of my holy and blessed mother so it is my will
that is celebrated it was my will alone at meter ascend so high and to distinguish her among all
everything else would have been is nothing that she not possessed the tragedy of my will
it was my will that gave her divine foot quantity and made her the mother of the divine word
it was my will that made her see and embrace all creatures together becoming the mother of all
mother of all nations
and loving all the love which was divine eternity making her the queen of all
it made her rule and dominate on that day my will received the first honors the glory and the
abundant fruit of its work and creation and the divine will began its feast never interrupts
with the glorification of the operating in my beloved mother and even though heaven was opened
by me and many saints were already in possession of the celestial fatherland when she was assumed
into heaven however she herself was the primary cause having fulfilled the supreme will in everything
and therefore we waited for her who had honored it so much and contained the true
tragedy of the most holy will so even though other saints had preceded her everything was
dependent on her because she was the only person who had done the divine will the only human being
who had done the divine will the first instance of her being for her last breath so make absolutely
sure that when you are making your your desires known to the lord that you say to him that in my
last breath i want to give you praise and honor and glory and power and majesty i want to join
the angels i want to join the saints i want to arrive tanking and praising and glorifying you
so my life will be worth it
i want to justify my being by giving you glory and honor and praise and majesty here on the earth
that's the thing we need to sort of be very conscious of he said everything
depended on what she did because she was the first one in the uh to keep the divine will
she herself was the primary cause having fulfilled the supreme will in everything and
therefore we waited for her who had honored the divine will so much and contained the true
tragedy of the most holy will to make the first beast of the supreme religion so it's in the
assumption that the divine will is honored oh how the whole of heaven magnified leston praised the
eternal will upon seeing this sublime queen entered the imperial heaven in the midst of the celestial
court all sir confused by the eternal song of the supreme volition that she arrived in heaven
with god in her entire being what an absolutely extraordinary thing they saw her all stuttered
with the power of the supreme fiat there had been not even a heartbeat in her which did not have
this fiat impressed on it wow and astonished they looked at her and they said to her ascend
as an entire it is right that she who so much honored the supreme fiat and true whom we find
ourselves in the celestial father hand have the highest throne and dr queen and the highest
honor that my mother received was to see the divine will be horrified so here's everybody
glorifying and honoring her but her only interest was in glorifying and honoring the divine will
so everything is in order everything is in its right place good stop there because
because of my age and I think as I can only do one hour so we'll stop there and just finish by
glorifying and praising god lord jesus we thank you for the immense privilege of knowing about
your divine will we thank you for the even greater privilege of stepping into your divine will
and consecrating ourselves to your divine will and jesus we lay the whole of our lives
all our thoughts words actions movements steps everything all our ambitions intentions everything
we put them all into the hands and into the immaculate heart of our dearest mother our queen
and yours and we ask her the mother of victories to bring us all to our destination through Christ
our lord good night everyone godly